check I need to get your insight on the
anonymous tip hotline what do you think
well I don't I don't condone snitching
snitches get stitches where I come from
I'm sure it's gonna be a lot of
frivolous calls I'm not really clear on
the rules I I was told that you can
leave and come back is that true I'm not
sure but you know it's gonna be
different for a lot of guys because heat
canvas okay well a didn't know that but
Dewayne Candace knows this all great
players have routines so the guys are
gonna have to adjust their routines and
this is something nobody's used to you
know we talked about you know last week
no team having really a clear-cut home
court advantage
so love the guys are on campus there's
no there's no family members as no wives
there's no girlfriends there's no
homeboys there's no shifts there's no
security guard so you really have to
bond with your teammates it's going to
be an interesting playoffs I think we're
gonna see a lot of a lot of sleepers
surprised and do something that that
wouldn't be done that this was regular
circumstances Adam I have a question for
Shaq Andy wait so where does a snitch of
a snitch cuz like Chris brought in
sources of the hotline of snitches but
then are you a snitch if you snitch on a
snitch
if me and D Way was still playing with
each other we don't see nothing I don't
see in d-wade do nothing I've never seen
Dewayne at a party I've never seen B way
break curfew I haven't seen D Wade do
anything wrong he's the perfect you know
he's one well this perfect image that
I've ever played with I feel like they
might have the role Chris right now I
feel like they given all this hate to
Chris Paul they might need to check on
Chris hangs out there with the
microphone reporting everything that's
going on it is funny because as soon as
this went out I believe it was reported
earlier today Twitter was going all over
that Chris Paul was the one out here
cinching says max
ending on Twitter for another I'm not
gonna do that to my guy yeah D waste
will see the one who told us Paul here
this is Shaq we're not doing that to my
god listen I'm a the president he's the
one that made the phone call D way was
he the one than me because the president
of the ABPA don't mean that he snitch
anyway okay make the phone call I don't
know I'm not okay don't be a tear
getting me Shaq don't don't be a tear
gave me over here maybe change my hands
he's not gonna say anything
I like that good teammate you know what
and I've been around all three of these
people they're incredible I've never
seen them do anything